welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division's finale
post-credits scene was
altered apparently by disney plus with
quite a few
unexplained and kind of creepy visual
changes that were not
in the original cut of this episode when
it was uploaded to the disney plus
platform on march 5th
among these alterations is what many
believe to be a mysterious spectral
forum gliding down the hillside toward
wanda maximoff's cabin
is this doctor strange as many of us
have theorized was a witness
of the scarlet witch's remote darkhold
research project or is it a glorified
lens flare or smudge that youtube
psychos like me are making too much out
of to try to justify your magical
thinking
to trust me that was my gut instinct too
the mepisto bullies have scarred me with
crippling self-awareness but
this smudge or anything underneath it in
the frame
was not in the original march 5th
version of the episode this was
added sometime recently also it's not
the only change to this footage
bfx artists for some reason added
several trees around the cabin
and removed a few birds that were
splashing around in the lake but perhaps
most tellingly marvel added to the
credits of the episode a credit for
composer michael chiquino for the use of
his
doctor strange theme which i previously
pointed out when the episode came out
has been audible over the shot of
wanda's astral projection with the dark
hole
now marvel did not have to do this they
could have just credited aquino's mcu
music contributions
in general since the opening fanfare
that we've heard behind every marvel
studios title since 2016
including episodes of one division was
originally composed by michael jacquino
as part of his work for the doctor
strange film but marvel went out of
their way to acknowledge his work for
the doctor strange theme
telling us that the overall purpose of
this re-edit might have been to better
link this finale and its post-credit
scene to the doctor strange films
really the additional post-production
work on this particular scene
might have been part of the
post-production on doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
which might now open with or at least
reuse this footage
as part of a new scene in that film
kevin feige himself
acknowledged that one division's finale
led to rewrites for multiverse of
madness and that a doctor strange cameo
was initially planned for the one
division finale but was removed part of
that plan
was to reveal the end universe
commercials were actually messages to
wanda from dr strange
and another was to feature doctor
strange as a ghostly blink and you'll
miss it cameo in the pharmacy for just
one frame
like brad pitt in fight club but even
before all of that was revealed after
wanda vision came out when we first saw
that scene
showing wanda using astral projection a
spell used by doctor strange and other
sorcerers
while the doctor strange music was
playing in an episode where ek the
harkness read from this dark hole spell
book that the scarlet witch's powers
surpassed those of the sorcerer supreme
aka steven strange
with camerawork that swoops in without
cutting into this cabin an homage to sam
raimi's shot in evil dead with raymie
directing multiverse of madness doctor
strange's coming conflict with wanda in
multiverse of madness has always been
the subtext of this scene
so much so that my interpretation of it
was that this was shot from strange's
point of view as his astral form swooped
down into this cabin to confront wanda
in this moment
and that's why she looked up suddenly
before we cut to black so now when this
floating ghostly shape now appears in
this one division post-credits scene
whenever you go on disney plus
again after nothing was there in the
original upload this starts to look at
least
a bit less batshit but here's what the
blur is exactly
notice that windowed wanda's left as she
turns to go in the door well in the
original version a
light shined off it or through it maybe
a reflection of the crew
i don't know i think it's barely
noticeable honestly but the vfx artist
decided to mask it out and then an
artifact of that mask was left
in that exact point in the frame perhaps
by mistake and since this is all part of
one tracking shot it just kind of stays
in that frame from the moment we cross
dissolve into this angle making it look
like something's floating down from the
mountains
i'm sorry to break any hearts hoping
that this could have been doctor strange
or spectral vision
but the fact remains that marvel vfx
editor still went
in to spruce up this footage with other
changes that were clearly intentional
and that is still
really weird and uncommon but uh before
i continue thanks to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero sugars and
zero artificial colors each 16 ounce can
contains
300 milligrams of caffeine coq10
and bcaas i'm sipping on pina colada
that nice tropical flavor that just
takes you to your happy place
but gives you the energy to fight off
any unwelcome tourists do showing too
much skin put your shirt on
i typically pop up in a bang when i need
to pick me up in the morning or when i
need to plow through a long video and
want my mind to be alert check out bang
on instagram get 10 off your order at
bangenergy.com when you use the code new
rockstars 10.
there you can buy a variety pack of bang
energy or grab a 12 pack of citrus twist
bankster berry or the new delish
strawberry kiss
use my code new rockstars 10 to receive
ten percent off your bang energy order
that's code new york starts 10 for 10
off
and assuming that these alterations were
intentional for marvel to have
any reason to reopen the one division
project file and tinker with it like
this
upload a new version hope no one notices
really the simplest explanation
is that marvel needed it to be done for
some upcoming project
meaning this could now be part of a
sequence in doctor strange and
multiverse of madness elizabeth olsen
stated that wanda will
soon be held accountable for trapping
the citizens of west view in hex
we could be seeing that reckoning here
in the cabin and that scene in
multiverse of madness could take place
immediately after wandavision cuts to
black
now with astrowanda in a kind of
sorcerer battle with astral steven
strange
and perhaps these trees were added
because when the extended version of
this cabin sequence was shot by
sam raimi for multiverse of madness that
fight takes place among this new setting
that they shot it in that just happened
to have more trees and branches so
to better dovetail it with what we saw
in one division they need to go back and
add more trees to be around that cabin
there
why do the water birds need to be
removed well maybe some of the spells
cast in this wizard
will kill any living creature in the
area or maybe wanda now reveals that she
created this mountain refuge to prevent
any other living creature from entering
that bubble including wild animals
similar to how in the west view hex any
physical thing that entered that bubble
was either blocked out or
warped and now in the new logic of the
scene it just wouldn't make sense for
outside ducks to be splashing around
nearby
all i know is that i am now gonna have
to go back through all the wanovision
scenes to see if anything else has been
changed nice going disney plus you just
boosted your streaming numbers with the
post-production equivalent of that high
school prank where you released chickens
and number them one two three and five
just
with the teachers but you can support
our madness here at new rockstars by
checking out our merch options
including our loki inspired shirt loki
at a time at newrockstarsmerch.com you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
eaboss follow and subscribing to
rockstars thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you